good idea welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight the president is rallying
supporters in Hershey Pennsylvania we'll
have highlights and news worthy moments
from his speech just ahead
but first tonight at 11:59 a.m. on
January 20th 2017 Donald Trump took the
oath of office to became the President
of the United States by 12:05 that same
day
Democrats were calling for his
impeachment and that's barely an
exaggeration if at all literally for
years the left has been howling the
Trump must be removed immediately from
office without the consent of voters
every day
finally today this day fewer than 11
months before the next presidential
election they explained precisely how
they plan to do that House Democrats
described their articles of impeachment
today watch the first article is for
abuse of power it is an impeachable
offense for the President to exercise
the powers of his public office to
obtain an improper personal benefit that
is exactly what President Trump did when
he solicited and pressured Ukraine to
interfere in our 2020 presidential
election this gives rise to the second
article of impeachment for obstruction
of Congress we must be clear no one not
even the president is above the law no
one is above the law
explain the very same people who spent
all day making excuses for illegitimate
government spying on American citizens
but never mind literally no one is above
the law
watch no one is above the law not even
the President of the United States no
one is above the law no one is above the
law no one is above the law not even the
President of the United States no one's
above the law No
is about all that no person is above the
law nobody should be above the law
yeah it's pretty simple you don't need a
law degree to understand it nobody is
above the law nobody except for the more
than 20 million illegal aliens who left
tell us have every right to be here
ignoring our laws and shut up racist if
you disagree also the so called homeless
shooting up and defecating and living
full-time on our sidewalks the law does
not apply to them or to subway jumpers
in New York or 200 biden but other than
that absolutely nobody is above the law
meaning Trump and that's why they're
impeaching him but they're not
celebrating that fact they know they're
not you might think they're excited but
they're not Democrats want to be
completely clear on this question
they're extremely troubled it has come
to this it is a sad day in Washington a
moment of poignant reflection a moment
redolent with sadness Nancy Pelosi and
Jerry Nadler and Adam Schiff and a
number of other people who've never had
a single authentic impulse in their
entire lives
would like you to know that they feel
extremely what's the word for this
solemn about what's happening they
seriously solemn good morning everyone
when the solemn day I'm I recall that
the first order of business for members
of Congress is the solemn act to take an
oath to protect and defend the
Constitution of the United States that
is why we must take this solemn step
today the president's oath of office
appears to mean very little to him but
the articles put forward today will give
us a chance to show that we will defend
the Constitution and that our oath means
something to us yeah and if that wasn't
entertaining enough and it was but there
was still more because this is
Washington there's always more dig your
handle deeper into the stocking another
present
today's was Chuck Schumer the
professional Wall Street shill who lies
for a living going onto the Senate floor
and accusing us this network and brace
yourself here free blast of irony
accusing FoxNews of being dishonest for
real watch the president conjures
fictions buys into baseless conspiracy
theories told by known wires on Fox News
or somewhere else here in the Senate
certain members of the grand old party
are forming their own conspiracy caucus
any crazy conspiracy where the launch by
Putin or some wild hey wild-eyed crazy
conspiracy theorists who manages of
course all the time to get on Fox News
and have his story or her story repeated
it's just such a shame Sigmund Freud has
fallen out of favor they were attacking
him on the college campuses as a success
we need Sigmund Freud today because
without Freud it's hard to recognize
what's going on but here it is distilled
to its essence write this down put it on
your fridge is the best guide to
politics ever what the left accuses you
of doing is precisely what they're doing
themselves they accuse you of fostering
racism pushing conspiracy theories lying
to finish the sentence of course those
are the three main things they're doing
and impeachment proves the point once
more the first article of impeachment
accuses the president of quote abuse of
power for quote soliciting the
interference of a foreign government
Ukraine in the twenty twenty United
States presidential election end quote
so just so you understand House
Democrats are arguing here that there
was no meddling in American politics
when Ukrainian energy company hired the
otherwise unemployable son of a sitting
vice president at an exorbitant rate for
no work at the very moment his father
was policing quote anti-corruption
efforts in their country there's nothing
political about that and if you think
otherwise you believe in a conspiracy
theory a debunked conspiracy theory a
theory
so debunked in fact that the president
committed a literally impeachable
offense simply by asking about it that's
right and you know what else wasn't at
all an abuse of power but really the
opposite of an abuse of power when the
last President President Obama killed a
US citizen without a trial using drone
strikes not an abuse of power are you
kidding that's another debunked
conspiracy theory or when he had the FBI
investigated rival presidential campaign
based on an obviously fraudulent dossier
of opposition research written by a
foreigner
using Intel from the Russian government
that was not an abuse of power what
you're crazy we work for Fox News or
something you freak and while we're on
the topic by the way the last several
presidents Bush Obama and yes being
honest no Trump have all overseen the
growth of a brand-new surveillance state
one aimed at you and me American
citizens that was not an abuse of power
all those people have launched new wars
have brought without bothering to ask
Congress in violation of the
Constitution of the United States which
requires them to do so explicitly not an
abuse of power with every passing year
the presidency becomes a lot more like a
monarchy not an abuse of power in fact
no big deal but ask about hunter Biden's
sleazy deal with the Ukrainians that's
it pal we're moving you from office now
the second article impeachment by the
way accused the president of obstruction
of Congress the crime here supposedly is
declined to comply with congressional
subpoenas subpoenas by the way like the
ones of the phone companies that got
people's phone records last week you saw
those but subpoenas related to the
impeachment process now if you don't
live in Washington you may not know that
neither party actually takes this
seriously both parties know it's not a
reason to impeach President Clinton
resisted subpoenas consistently
constantly during his impeachment saga
21 years ago nobody remembers that
nobody would care if they did remember
it so we'll spare you any long
explanation of it but it happened come
on no this is about actual high crimes
and misdemeanors they're not even trying
to make that case why is this happening
you know why two reasons first Democrats
at least their troops on Twitter still
haven't accepted the defeat of 2016
they think impeachment would nullify
that shocking loss like it never
happened and allow them to ignore every
lesson that came with that
election the lessons that both our
parties needed to learn but didn't and
have no interest in learning they can
continue to ignore those because Trump
was impeached he was an anomaly some
weird orange guy showed up for a few
years but we kicked him out we don't
need to think about why voters would
have supported him in the first place
but the other reason is looking to the
future
some Democrats and they're not all dumb
that's for sure some of them sincerely
believe that impeachment will help their
case in the 2020 elections it'll unify
their base it'll demoralize the
opposition and Republicans humiliate the
president it'll improve their chances of
winning the presidential election
are they right about that we don't
really know but we do know that as of
tonight polling suggests maybe it's not
that simple so for example every three
months
firehouse strategies here in Washington
has been polling voters in Wisconsin
Pennsylvania and Michigan those are of
course the three critical swing states
that made trump president in 2016 in all
the previous polls this year conducted
by firehouse the president trail Joe
Biden in every one of those states but
in firehouses most recent poll Trump is
leading Biden and every other Democrat
in all three states now the economy is
obviously rolling along according to
some measurements anyway that's clearly
helping the president but it does seem
like at the very moment Trump is being
impeached his numbers should be going
down and they're not they're going up so
it's possible that instead of securing
victory in 2020 these impeachment
efforts could be leading the Democrats
into a catastrophe and why wouldn't that
be the case because when you strip away
all the analysis here's the bottom line
polls show consistently that for most
voters the ones who aren't on Twitter
full-time impeaching the president is
not even close to the top of their list
of priorities they care about the things
you'd expect them to care the things
that you care about no matter what party
you're registered with health care wages
student loan debt which really is
wrecking the country crime which is real
and rising the border which is open it's
not even a border anymore and this about
every other issue that's not impeachment
and that shouldn't surprise you because
those issues actually affect people even
more brace yourselves now even more than
internal Ukrainian politics so every day
the Democrats continue to focus all of
their energy and all of our attention
here in the media on impeachment they're
also sending a signal to voters it's
pretty clear and it's we don't care what
you think